madame la présidente m.  vice-président membres
du Congrès distingués invités mes
compatriotes américains la Chine n'attend pas pour
réorganiser son économie l'Allemagne
n'attend pas et il n'attend pas ces
nations ne tiennent pas
bien en place je n'accepte pas la deuxième place pour
les États-Unis d'Amérique nous le savons
ce qu'il faut pour concourir pour les emplois
et les industries de notre temps, nous
devons innover, éduquer et construire plus que
le reste du monde, nous pouvons soit nous
contenter d'un pays où un
nombre décroissant de personnes réussissent très bien tandis qu'un nombre
croissant  nombre d'Américains s'en sortent à
peine ou nous pouvons restaurer une économie où
tout le monde obtient une chance équitable et chacun
fait sa juste part et tout le monde joue
selon le même ensemble de règles,
c'est la tâche de nos générations alors de
rallumer le véritable moteur de la
croissance économique américaine une montée
classe moyenne florissante, la dure réalité est que même
au milieu de la reprise, trop d'
Américains travaillent plus que jamais juste pour s'en sortir et
encore moins pour aller de l'avant et trop
encore  ne fonctionnent pas bien du tout, nous
acceptons une économie où seuls quelques-uns d'entre nous
réussissent de manière spectaculaire ou allons-nous nous engager
dans une économie qui génère
des revenus et des chances croissants pour tous ceux
qui font l'effort